we received some very interesting news over
the weekend.
Donald Trump's latest former national security
advisor is in negotiation to testify in Donald
Trump's impeachment inquiry, and if he does,
this is testimony that could completely blow
up Donald Trump Bolton.
To be clear is a disgusting neo-con Warhawk
from the era of George W. Bush.
He was regularly at odds with Donald Trump
during his tenure as national security advisor,
but he may indeed be just a major player in
exposing how bad the corruption is under Donald
Trump Bolton's lawyers, and of course everyone
associated with Donald Trump seems to end
up needing lawyers.
Even Trump's own lawyers making attorneys
get attorneys the alternate interpretation
for Maga Bolton's lawyers say they're talking
to the committees that are involved in the
impeachment inquiry and that John Bolton may
indeed be deposed.
It is alleged that during Bolton's time as
national security advisor, he would regularly
criticize Rudy Giuliani for Rudy's efforts
to dig up dirt on Biden and he would call
them drug deals.
He would call what Rudy Giuliani was doing
drug deals.
He would encourage staffers at the national,
uh, the, at the a NSA to report this stuff
to administration lawyers.
It's unclear if those reports ever actually
took place.
So far it's been mostly not very well known
diplomats who have been testifying as part
of this impeachment inquiry.
But this would very quickly change if John
Bolton were to testify.
And it is really important to remember that
truly horrible people like John Bolton can
be useful in a fight against Donald Trump's
corruption and self enrichment and peddling
influence for his own benefit.
Bolton is disgusting.
I mean this, this was one of the architects
of the Iraq war.
Bolton represents the worst of the neo-conservative
impulses of the last several decades of American
foreign policy.
But listen, if he's useful, then have him
testify.
Why not?
There are people hoping that this will be
an open door testimony.
Uh, but it wouldn't be that part of this is
actually about preventing witnesses from coordinating
their stories and if these testimonies were
in open were public, you could have a witness
come in and say something and then you could
have other witnesses hear that and then go
in and tell the same or a very similar story
to make it seem as though everything is on
the up and so that's not the way that it's
going to happen.
The really interesting thing here is that
the instincts that are natural to John Bolton
for which we are disgusted by him, right?
I mean his bloodthirsty take, no prisoners,
reactionary nature.
That may be what ultimately leads him to show
up and to take down Donald Trump Bolton in
the end is total pond scum.
I mean the guy's a complete bloodthirsty bottom
theatre, but he will do what he sees as patriotic
and it just might be like we might just happen
to overlap in that he will see denouncing
and exposing what Donald Trump has done as
the patriotic thing to do.
His values are counter to most of our values
in my audience would be my guests, but they
might overlap in that we all think Donald
Trump should be held accountable.
We all think, hopefully if John Bolton does,
we all believe that there should be consequences
to actions taken by presidents of the United
States.
And in fact, it actually sort of stunningly
shows us how bad things have gotten that in
the Trump administration's current and former
staffers, someone is antithetical to my values
and to what I believe our American values
as John Bolton might end up being a sort of
defacto good guy.
And I use that term, I mean it's like painful
to use it about Bolton, but he may end up
serving the role of a good guy in this particular
very narrow set of circumstances by showing
up and just telling the truth about what he
saw.
And to be clear, he's not a good guy.
He may play one in this fiasco involving the
Donald Trump administration.
Of course, I'll keep you posted on the latest
news about John Bolton's testimony.
Uh, we also are there.
There's a bigger list of people.
Again, listen, I mean we, we've been talking
about in the end if Democrats don't enforce
subpoenas, this is all just BS.
That's the reality.
There are higher level people that have been
had documents subpoenaed and who may be subpoenaed
personally to testify.
We'll get into it if and when it looks like
they actually might otherwise.
The story I'm going to have to keep telling
you is that spineless Democrats refuse to
actually attempt to enforce the subpoenas.
Now, every time I say that, people email me
and say, David, come on.
You know it is not ultimately up to Democrats
whether the subpoenas are enforced.
Trump controls this, that and the other thing
and are you really going to see the Sergeant
at arms of the house go and hold people in
contempt?
I'm not there yet.
All I'm saying is let's at least see Democrats
try to enforce the subpoenas and then if they
try and are stonewalled, then we'll deal with
that.
We'll cross that bridge when we come to it.
But a priori saying it doesn't matter if Democrats
try to enforce them because it's not going
to be, you know, it's not going to be Nancy
Polosi personally going and slapping the cuffs
on anyone.
Depends is whether the systems in place will
do it.
Let's see the Democrats try first and then
see how far
we get.